a brand new month is approaching and
that means it's the perfect time
to let go you can play the 30-day
minimalism game and also
download our free printable 30-day
minimalism game calendar
over at theminimalists.com game
enjoy minimalists
let's see here we have a question here
from jacob
do paper straws and sip cups sip cup
lids really help
um so paper sip cup lids paper straws
what are your thoughts on on the paper
strolls i mean obviously you
prefer them to plastic but they're
probably not the best alternative either
so for me i believe in lifting the cup
up to my mouth and drinking
so that's my way actually so i'm not
really astrology conservative yeah i say
it so smoothly right nobody even thinks
about what i'm about to tell them this
is like such a
mind-blowing thing but i definitely i'm
not really a straw person i've never
really needed them
i do want to put a disclaimer out there
i did go to the city of new york to try
and help them with the ban of plastic
straws and
there was a very big population of folks
with disabilities who made sure that we
understood that it is really really
really important for them to have
plastic straws so i want to put that out
there that we are not
trying to be insensitive to anyone's
needs um
what i believe is there's a lot of
reusable
alternatives that you can use that
actually are better than the paper
straws
because they don't disintegrate they
don't melt um there's steel ones there's
glass ones there's silicone ones there's
great options and there's
collapsible ones that you could just put
in your bag your pocket
so i think that that's kind of the new
way of of doing things it's just the
reusables are the best
options and again like the good old
lifting the cup to your mouth
i really like that the best yeah yeah it
works for me
i was um on rodeo drive recently
i like to do like a i don't know if you
would call this like an anthropological
experiment but i i
i really enjoy just seeing the the sort
of
i avoid malls like crazy so this is like
where i go it's sort of
i i'm the fly on the wall i still refuse
to go into stores but
even now during covid uh
you see people waiting in line to get
into
these stores so like a gucci or
louis vuitton or wherever and they're
waiting a long line but
i bring this up because we're talking
about waste
if you walk past these stores their
doors are wide open it's a hundred
degrees in los angeles
but they're air conditioning rodeo drive
and it's a tremendous amount of waste uh
and i'm just wondering what your
thoughts are on
on because it doesn't even seem that
we're it seems to me that that is a
no-brainer to just shut your doors but i
understand why they do it as a person
who used to run a bunch of retail stores
himself
i understand why they do it but it seems
like incredibly wasteful there should be
some sort of backlash to this no
i mean i think precoved if you leave
your door closed and expect
a customer to push it and walk in your
chances of getting them in
is way lower you're right 100 but that
also being said like if you go to las
vegas in the summer or even in the
winter really but mostly in the
summertime
you are freezing inside to the point
where you actually need a jacket a coat
something you can't just go with what
you'd wear on a summer day inside any of
these places
i have family that lives in europe and
that is their biggest pet peeve about
america is
why does it have to be so cold so just
changing the degree of the thermostat
slightly
it is such a huge difference with the
output of energy that we need
so i recommend if you can just like
knock it up just a couple degrees
it changes the game you know ever i
don't know what the exact
um conversion is to how much waste
energy is wasted
but just a few degrees up it will make
the biggest difference and i really
think like
we shouldn't be that cold inside a space
um during you know a hot day yeah yeah
it doesn't make sense to if i'm walking
by listen i'm cold even though i'm
outdoors
uh and it just it's a bit of a pet peeve
of mine
um we've talked about clothing waste
already i mean i think what is it
something like 88 pounds a year of
clothing is
is thrown away per person yeah
phenomenal we we we covered that it's
it's just it's mind-blowing but how do
you deal with that well you you bring in
less stuff you
get higher quality items that you feel
good about wearing
avoid trends obviously fast fashion yes
let's talk about fast fashion a bit yeah
you know right now i have a 13 year old
daughter who is like
on tick tock and there's these companies
where she's like mom can i buy this can
i buy that and it's like
the shirt is four dollars and the skirt
is seven dollars and like
it's just like she could probably buy a
whole new wardrobe for a hundred dollars
and
i asked her i said if you think that it
makes sense for this item that costs
this much money to arrive
all the way to your house right here in
los angeles how much money do you think
the person who's making this
is getting paid how do you think it's
impacting the environment do you think
that they're making good decisions and
she's like
probably not and i said i'd much prefer
you pick one thing
somewhere and be you know trendier than
um
and have that one thing to mix in with
all the items that you have but be
responsible about it you know
it is so unfortunate to see the amount
of advertising that's happening for fast
fashion to these young kids
who want to look cool who want to be you
know and it's affordable and it just
seems like the perfect mix to keep them
looking cool
um we're going it's like swimming
upstream uh with this stuff but
you know it i think the parents out
there need to really make
a point at not buying this stuff for
them just you know
once in a blue moon fine but like i'd
rather get one good thing that lasts you
till you're in college right a good
sweater a good pair of jeans
something like that yeah and i find that
as a minimalist like the clothes that i
wear i tend to enjoy much more than
the oversized orange sweatshirt with
tassels that was in the back of the
closet that i never wore but
i bought it because it might have looked
okay on a mannequin in 2006. like
it's it we we we often make purchases
that are aspirational purchases
and i think it's really it's really
amplified by what's going on with the
advertisements now on places like tick
tock or instagram
because not only are they insidious
maybe the most insidious part is that
they're
highly targeted they know everything
about the
the demography of the user and then
they are experts at surgically inserting
the ad that spikes your cortisol
getting it on that influencer that they
all look up to i mean it's a
it's a really tough thing however i'll
tell you one thing the most
well-dressed in my opinion the most
well-dressed elegant men and women
in the world are in france and you go to
france and you go sit down in one coffee
shop and it's like a fashion show in
front of you
but guess what their culture is built
upon the idea that you only buy
three or four things per year and that's
it and those three or four things will
last you forever and they're good things
and you just buy classic elegant things
and it you just learn how to mix and
match and accessorize and
you never throw anything away because
every single thing in your closet is
good
and i just always remind myself of that
every time you know you see a sale or
something like
let me just take a look no wait and just
think about you know what do i have how
can i mix in and
and build it that way let's pivot to
talking about
factory farming and some of the the
environmental problems with factory
farming
yeah this is hard for me because um i
just was on the 5 freeway driving up to
lake tahoe which is like my heaven
and i'm driving up there and i see that
it's getting
really hot it's like 108 109 on the road
and i look to my right and there's these
massive cattle farms
and they don't have any shade there's
just brown dirt everywhere
you can see how horrible this is you go
up further and you see these little
boxes that are plastic boxes
with a cage in front of it and there's
one bowl of water
no shade i think those plastic boxes
must have had 130 degree temperature and
that was where they were raising veal
and their baby cows that just get to
come out one step so that their muscles
don't get firm
they don't get to walk have some water
and then retract back in
so i again did some research and i had
this idea like
what if we were able to have some kind
of visibility between the end user
the consumer and the farmers many
farmers are proud of their farms and
they would
happily show what's going on but most of
the time they're not proud so why is it
that we're not allowing them
why aren't we putting pressure on them
to show us what's going on what's the
temperature what are these animals
treated like
that being said i think we also have
power once again
so studies show from oxford that if we
decrease
our animal protein intake by 50
per person some say 40 that's about 8 or
10 meals a week okay
we can completely alter the direction in
which the planet is going
all these fires all these the amazon
everything
so again how easy is it there's like
huge new york times full
page um you know dedicated to vegan
eating
and you're not really missing anything
so it's not like it's every meal needs
to be
animal protein you know against popular
belief that we need so much
we really don't so i believe in
part-time veganism
i think it's a thing that we really need
to recognize because sometimes people
are just like
forget it i can't even do it so hands up
i'm done i'm not even gonna try
it's not all or nothing you're saying
it's not and if again try 40
25 start with your creamer that's what i
say to everybody
start with your creamer can you do can
you have a cup of coffee with almond
milk or oat milk or something
coffee maybe black coffee see how that
goes and
build from there and see what what a
difference it makes you know
i think there are little modifications
we can make that really don't
actually take too much energy no skin
off your back just give it a go
and then try a meal that has no animal
protein and see how that goes and then
again build on that and then try to
sprinkle it in many more times during
the week
and then when you are eating animal
proteins you know a place like uh
there's a farm here in california
belcampo
where they you know they even like they
do field trips for kids and show them
about
regenerative agriculture versus factory
farming
and how they can actually improve the
land with what they're doing with
with their cows and with all of their
animals
and so um we're talking about quality of
life for those animals
as well versus the hideous scene that
you saw
driving to tahoe where it's borderline
torture
it is torture i mean i wouldn't even
call it borderline it is
because that heat um biggest little farm
is another movie that my family loves
it's a great documentary it won
so many awards and it talks about this
this woman and this man who got married
and decided that
they really wanted to buy a farm and
they made the most beautiful farm with
like i think 70 different
varieties of fruits and vegetables and
it is this like total antithesis to mono
agriculture where you're just seeing
rows and rows of one product one item
being grown which is not really
sustainable
no especially when those mono crops are
almost always
corn or soy and those aren't good for us
either right i mean
you can go on a vegan diet and eat oreos
and palm oil and nutella and all these
other things but like
that's not the healthy option either we
still want nutrient-dense food whether
we're eating animal products or
or we're eating plants we want to make
sure that what we're what we're
consuming is nutrient dense it's
chemical free and uh it's become a
full-time job for
for many of us to just try to navigate
those those waters well i'll tell you
this
um one of the things that we really like
to emphasize is that it's a much more
cost effective way to eat as well
so this is not you know aside from like
all the environmentalism kind of being
geared towards the rich and you know the
privileged
this type of eating is actually a lot
easier for
many people um around the globe to
partake in
you know buying a bag of lentils is so
much less
expensive than a steak for you know four
people
so what i was just going to add one more
little bit to this
is in in in actuality part-time veganism
is a term we came up with
it's a great way to start and there's no
guilt or shame
if you can't you know succeed that first
week
this is about just an invitation to try
something new and experience
a friend of mine said sheila i love the
way you guys do it at habits of weights
it's like you're on the runway with
those lights
with the airplane and that's the way
people usually go and you're like hey
look at this way maybe try this way and
see how this feels
and that's our goal it's to not make
people feel bad
or that there's a line between us and
them and environmentalists no
you know i didn't grow up as an
environmentalist i just find
it fascinating to look at society and
and behavior as a whole
and so for me the you know the runway
can maybe be a little bit further to the
left or the right just try something new
and then try and then say no but give it
a go i really like that we've had
our good friend rich roll on the podcast
i don't know if you know rich but he's a
vegan athlete and uh just an amazing
human being
brilliant man um he's in his 50s now but
does triathlons and like i i
i hope that i'm as fit as him someday i
wish i was as fit as
him now but he's just he's an amazing
person and uh we've had him on the
podcast several times we did an entire
food podcast with him
he talked about the cost-effectiveness
of of his diet
um and then we also had we brought him
on with a
carnivore doctor dr paul saladino who
surprisingly even though the two of them
had zero
overlap on the venn diagram of their
diet the venn diagram of their values
was
very much overlapped because you know
paul really cared about sustainability
and and go being
avoiding factory farming just like rich
did and
what i realized is that when we start
making intentional choices with our food
you know i'm like the 99.6
of the population who is an omnivore and
and so i i didn't follow either one of
their diets necessarily but what i got
from both of them
is that they both make intentional
choices with what they put into their
body and we tend to be healthier when we
do that
and right now everything is coming in
all this plastic packaging and
there's nothing really intentional about
that we what was the quote um
oh i think aaron mcmanus said it last
time we were
if you can't read it don't eat it uh i
mean i think it's a ron functions quote
or something but
it's uh there's so many just ingredients
that
i can't even tell you what they are i
can't even read it let alone tell you
what it is
we can all do a little bit better i
think and you know perfection
is the enemy of good enough and our
philosophy is that if there's this many
people on the planet doing a little bit
every day i think we'll be in a better
place i agree
absolutely